hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show thank you for
listening we have an incredible guest
today and his name is Ed Catmull he is
the co-founder of Pixar Animation
Studios which he started with Steve Jobs
and John Lasseter and president of Pixar
Animation and Disney Animation and has
also received five Academy Awards and as
a computer scientist he has contributed
to many of the most important
developments in computer graphics he has
done a hell of a lot and in this episode
we talk about many different things the
birth of Pixar his background going from
a technician to more of a manager
president in this particular case the
creative process storytelling how they
embrace it and developed it within Pixar
the mistakes they've made what they've
thrown out and much much more
including the lessons that he's learned
the things he's observed working with
people like George Lucas and Steve Jobs
before we get to the interview two
things that I'd like to provide the
first is a quote and this is from Harry
Truman and it is as follows it is
amazing what you can accomplish if you
do not care who gets the credit
and in fact Ronald Reagan has a very
very similar quote to this effect the
next is a Japanese proverb of course you
know I'm a Japanophile I used to live
there and I love sharing code Aliza or
Japanese proverbs and there are many we
talked about the Saturday mochi consider
a few episodes back and this time we
have Chattanooga Haute okay sheeran got
Haute okay she Donna is not knowing God
is a subject marker basically Haute okay
so not knowing is Buddha what the hell
does that mean [ __ ] I knew got Haute
okay means ignorance is bliss or what
you don't know can't hurt you and the
way that I interpret this as it applies
to this particular episode is sometimes
to do the incredible you have to go in
somewhat naive and if you knew what
you're getting yourself into you
probably wouldn't sign up in the first
place so beginner mind or being a novice
or jumping into the unknown can
sometimes allow you to do what you would
otherwise be told is impossible
without further ado I want to get us to
the interview if you want all the
transcripts the links the show notes and
everything else please go to four hour
work week comm forward slash podcast all
spelled out for our work week comm
forward slash podcast and if you'd like
to support the show please go to my book
club and you can find a number of books
that have changed my life that's four
hour work week comm forward slash books
hope you enjoy and thank you for
listening
at this altitude I can learn if I have
or a half mile before my hands start
shaking so much for joining me today for
a conversation I hope I hope you enjoy
it and I've been looking forward to it
for quite some time
my pleasure this is somewhat of a
landmark moment for me because I feel
like destiny has had this in the cards I
remember 1995 very clearly for a lot of
reasons but one of them was that I
bought my first ever share of stock and
that was in Pixar and it was also I
guess the last year of Calvin and Hobbes
so it was a very emotional year for me
but I have been following comic book art
animation and Pixar for as long as I
have known of it and of course as
co-founder you've had a key role in
creating a lot of the stories that I can
pretty much play back sort of frame by
frame line by line and of course I'd
like to talk about that but also
creativity Inc and the book that you've
put out which Forbes has said might just
be the best business book ever written
which is a very strong testimonial what
I'd love to ask you is perhaps starting
with a defining moment and maybe it
wasn't a defining moment when Pixar went
public what did that feel like do you
remember that day extremely clearly or
was it not a defining moment well the
time we went public which is in 1995 was
actually very close to a number of other
events that happen around the same time
so I look at it as a
period of time and for me it was a
pivotal year mm-hmm but we went public
one week after the movie came out right
very smart so Steve Jobs logic was that
well he wanted us to go public and he
had some reasons for it which we were
skeptical of to be honest but he wanted
to do it after the film came out to
demonstrate to people that in fact a new
art form was being born mm-hmm that was
worth investing in so the film came out
it was a big success it was a success
for me in the sense that we had made a
film and it wasn't just a technical tour
de force mm-hmm I never thought of this
is we can demonstrate technically we can
do it but we actually wanted to make a
real honest-to-goodness complete film
just had that goal in mind and that's
what we achieved it was also the
culmination of 20 years of pursuing this
dream mm-hmm so there is within the
short period of time the culmination of
20 years the achieving of a goal going
public mm-hmm starting off on our next
film and actually will begin to think
about two films the other being poor
story to having a relationship with
Disney mm-hmm and while all this was
going on I personally felt a sense of
loss hmm and there was a curious one
mm-hmm
because I had just achieved this goal
but the loss was in having achieved the
goal
I was now missing one of the defining
frameworks so I went through a period of
a year of trying to sort this out and I
realized as I went through that year
mm-hmm that there were some really
exciting things observed along the way
and one of them that I observed was that
most successful companies have this arc
where they rise and then with that
success most of them fail already fell
quickly but a lot of them they take
longer but ultimately they fall apart
mm-hmm and so the question was okay how
do you make it so that it's sustained a
mmm-hmm because the people that I knew
of her in these companies and I had a
lot of friends in Silicon Valley were
smart and they were creative and they
were hard-working so whatever the
problem was there was actually leading
them astray was really hard to see and
the implication was that whatever that
force was it would also apply to us at
Pixar mmm-hmm
so this then became the interesting
question these forces are at work can we
find them before they do it in mmm-hmm
and so at the end of the Arthur I
realized this is actually the next call
it's not a film if how do we have an
environment in which we can find and
address these problems mm-hmm so so that
was the big thing I got in the year at a
personal level there was another one
also which was not in the book but I
always tell you about it because it was
a personal thing for me and that was
when I was younger I remember this
thinking at some point I want to be the
best in the world of something mm-hmm
could go alright so this is a goal that
I had so now it's 20 years later the
film comes out and then I were
successful and there are these
phenomenal people here there are the
technical people most of whom weren't
well-known but you've got bill Reeve in
heaven auspey and did like that that
helped build the technology besides John
Lasseter and Steve Jobs
there also is ander Stanton and Joe raft
and Leung courage and Pete docter and
the whole bunch of people were part of
this hmm so now being part of this group
that achieved something there was a
question that I asked myself which I
didn't admit to anybody at the time and
that was well all of this were all of us
were part of this but how much of it was
me mm-hmm right so this is this
background question so well I know I'm
part of it and I'm only part of it but
how critical was I to this and and at
the end of the year as the goal became
clear I also realized that the question
was not a useful question
and that in somehow trying to do that I
was actually misleading myself now the
only reason I bring this out was that I
now recognize that a lot of people when
they reach that place where they're
successful they asked that question and
most people won't admit it but they do
ask the question and a lot of people
reach the wrong conclusion why is it
misleading and what is the conclusion
that they come to well what I believe is
that what we did together it was not
something that I can separate myself
from and this is true of most
enterprises there's a desire to separate
oneself out is like asking for a clean
answer to a question when there is no
clean answer right and it is true of
most of the things in our lives with its
personal or business is that the inner
connection between them and the way
they're all mixed together is inherently
messy mmm-hmm confusing and there aren't
clear boundaries and the desire for
complete clarity actually leads one away
from addressing the mess that's in the
middle hmm you know this is a reminds me
of a conversation I had recently with a
very successful trader on Wall Street
who said it's better to be roughly
correct than precisely wrong and it
seems like that mess in the middle is
something that a lot of people strive to
avoid give it an incredible technical
pedigree and of course we could talk
about the ARPA group we could talk about
your work early on with all sorts of
technologies that then have become
standard technologies in the use of
animation texture mapping and so on when
my close friends actually who was a
musician by training ended up working at
Pixar I believe he's still there because
he wrote a thesis at Princeton about
texture mapping of all things encoded it
himself but what I'd love to get your
thoughts on is as someone who's
exceptionally well trained in computer
science and engineering how did you take
that precision of a thought that logical
approach to problem solving and
replicating issues and so on which which
I
find translates into many different
areas and apply it to storytelling and
what is in your in your current role and
in previous roles would have been your
sort of key observations with how to
apply framework and I'll and just one
more comment that related to my
one-and-only tour of Pixar I live in San
Francisco and ended up having a friend
of a friend it was an engineer at Pixar
besides Rob my previous friend and I was
so impressed by the process I mean you
do have processes and doesn't mean
everything as a home run but I remember
looking at the color sort of the color
coding of different segments of the
films and I had never observed it and it
was it was so genius to me when to see
it laid out in front of me and that it
was a deliberate decision so that's a
mouthful that I just put out there but
with an engineering mind what have you
observed about storytelling and why
can't other companies get it right so
consistently or people well okay so I've
got three or four things to respond to
there so let me take as one of those
this has to do with the relationship
between the precision of the science and
on the art side mm-hmm for that I go
back to when I was growing up in the 50s
and a rather unique time in post-world
War two but also very safe times and as
I was growing up my two people that I
aspired to follow was Walt Disney in an
Albert Einstein but for most of my
childhood I wanted to be an artist I
want to be an animator and I studied art
and I did very well in art in high
school and I also did very well in
physics but as I got to near the end of
high school and going into college I
didn't see the path to get to the level
of what the animators were at at Disney
so when I went to college I switched
over into physics mm-hmm now the
interesting thing to me is that over the
years I've actually told that anecdote
to people when I've given talks all I
said I switched over and and I say
rather abruptly like they're not
supposed to go into physics and usually
there's a titter in the audience sort of
like
that's an incongruous statement right
but then that caused me to think about
its like okay why is that incongruous
mm-hmm because most people to this day
think of them as is so radically
different from each other but I want to
posit a different way to look at it and
it comes from I think what is a
fundamental misunderstanding of art on
the part of most people because they
think of art as learning to draw or to
learning a certain kind of
self-expression but in fact what artists
do is they learn to see mmm right
observe and the actual training is one
of observation so now if you if you look
at it from that point of view is okay so
which are the professions in which
observation is not important about
doctors or engineers or scientists if
you want the skills of observing and for
me there are different ways of looking
at things and if you look at the
storytelling side then the first
realization and I think I understood
this fairly early on is that
storytelling is the way we communicate
with each other all the way from when
you're reading to your children when
they're young but it's also the news and
magazines and the movies and television
and storytelling is a way we do things
but even in our education our good
teachers whether good teachers for
telling us good stories
their way of communicating understanding
and what our scientists and biologists
and neuroscientists trying to do they're
trying to reach an understanding and
then they're trying to find ways of
communicating that understanding to
other people mm-hmm these are all
different elements of the way we
communicate with each other and and it's
even stronger than most people think
because if you if you take something
complicated like making a movie who is
an example so you've got a few hundred
people working on a movie like it could
be Toy Story but it could be more recent
films
well what is the story of the making of
the film
well it turns out it's too complicated
to tell nobody writes that story now and
if you wrote down all the complexities
of what it took to do any one of these
major complexities that full story is
too boring mm-hmm is too long so what do
you do you tell a story but you edit it
down and you simplify it mm-hmm
so you simplify it in order to convey
certain of the ideas that are critical
but you can't capture all of them so you
end up with a kind of mythology and a
mythology is a way of us teaching basic
principles to each other but the
mythologies don't capture everything and
they never can mm-hmm so we are in a
continual state of trying to create our
own mythology's and even when we come up
with a mythology like the things we did
on Toy Story 2 mm-hmm the people who are
here at Pixar a lot of them weren't here
when we made toward story - so the
pivotal experiences that are there which
are part of our history were not
experienced by a lot of the people who
are here and you can't actually pass
that on as a story because then begins
to take on it like it fades over time
right to a pithy essence but in a longer
is a personal thing mm-hmm so what you
want is a new crisis and in solving the
new crisis which they experienced mm-hmm
then they get something different then
they can get by hearing about somebody
else's story so we have a combination of
both
storytelling and experiencing and we
need both in the crisis case are these
crises that organically appear in the
making of every movie or are the things
that you deliberately bring to a head or
manufacturer in some way to galvanize
the troops and inspire creativity well I
think in order for them to be successful
they essentially need to be organic
so if you manufacture crisis and you can
affect it somewhat obviously because if
you set a budget or you set a schedule
right for instance and it's very
difficult then to some extent you are
creating a crisis mm-hmm but even that's
a little artificial because the fact is
if you don't meet the scheduler if you
don't meet the budget you have a
different crisis right mm-hmm so what
you want are the kind of crises that
arise out of the thing that you're doing
but but you don't artificially generate
it done it so I don't think of setting a
budget or schedule as an artificial
generation of a crisis but if we have a
surprise that happens because things
never go according to plan then what you
want to do is use the problem that's
there as a way of getting you as a group
to force the change in the process or to
figure out problems in order to solve it
and in doing so it becomes a combined
joint effort to move everybody forward
and everybody has ownership in it to
come back to one of the things you said
earlier or one of the terms used
mythology looking at say Joseph Campbell
where she cited quite a lot in the
hero's journey or the euro Thousand
Faces are there any other books or
resources besides your own of course
which I would recommend everybody that
people can use to learn about mythology
or these sort of archetypal structures
to aid them in developing their own
ability to tell stories are there any
other books or resources that come to
mind as being particularly outstanding
or people irrelevant
yeah it's fairly broad because I've been
influenced by so many people and so many
different things I will say one thing
that I did which was informative but in
ways that are hard to articulate mm-hmm
you came from this thing in just my
brain works differently it turns out I
am unable to read poetry huh no kidding
because reading poetry within a few
seconds shuts my brain down why is the
eyes okay
well it was just differences I was I was
actually describing this to somebody
this is many years ago
and they said well don't read it listen
to it and the list came about because
there was a new translation of the Iliad
hmm by Thomas fagles and it was in verse
form hmm so the thing is I couldn't read
it so this woman at a dinner said well
don't read it listen to it so I bought
the Cape and I listened to it and I
found I was completely enthralled with
it
and then I was surprised by the fact
that here's a story that was orally
transmitted twenty-eight hundred years
ago in a different language to a
different culture and it was meant for
oral transmission of course because they
had kind of that rhythm to it right but
now translated all these years later
into English the fact that I had this
oral nature - it still worked and
captivated me and I was able to enjoy
and pull in this entire story so that so
that got me started down this path hmm
so what I did was I then started
listening to these lectures from the
teaching company mm-hmm and they had
these absolutely marvelous lecturers so
what I did was I tried to listen to
lectures of all of human history
so there's ancient Egypt and Mesopotamia
and Israel and China and India and going
up through the Roman era through the
Dark Ages the Middle Ages the
Renaissance mm-hmm took a few years so
every day in the car I would listen to
this but I felt like I had this grand
sweep of history mm-hmm now at some
level it's all pretty high level just
listening to lectures in a car right but
there was something about that which
gave me a sense which I loved and it
gave me a different feeling about people
and how things relate to each other so
that was one level of things the second
is there are like the wisdom books out
of various traditions and China and
India and meditation and things coming
out of Greece and Israel and so forth
and somehow reading all of those and the
way people rest for those things which
are the foundations of our culture I
found
formative now do you mean the the both
the classics and the religious texts and
scriptures like the whether it's the the
Torah or the daodejing
what type of yes all of those all the
boys I mean you take all of those and
say okay there's something about a
breath so I don't try to grab one of
them I try to get the breath there
mm-hmm because I do believe that we are
better off if we experience wide breath
that's what a general education is
mm-hmm and then there's some point at
which we dive really deep mm-hmm and
assume people want to specialize like I
just want to do this I just want to be
an artist or I just want to be a
scientist and so forth so I understand
that and there's an experience of diving
deep into something which is
indescribable so it's good to have that
experience and I think one has to breath
that if you you need a combination of
the two
and once you experience the depth and
something you're actually in a better
position to go deeper into an area once
you've discovered what your area of love
is mm-hmm then there's the more modern
thing in terms of neuroscience and how
we work and and then the other is just
the observation of if you look at what
took place in in Silicon Valley and
continues to take place in Silicon
Valley and in San Francisco and the rise
in the fall of the companies and the way
they interact and the amazing things
that happens and the bad things that
happen that human drama I find very
interesting mm-hmm and we're kind of in
the middle of it absolutely that's cool
so you know how do you look at that the
mess that we they were in and the good
things that were in parlors I moved to
the Bay Area and then gravitated up to
San Francisco from the peninsula it was
because of that that chaos and the
creation in that chaos you mentioned
specialization when you've obviously
done a lot of work with George Lucas and
Steve Jobs do you view them as
generalists specialists or both we're
some of the key habits or routines
rituals anything that either of them had
that they'd still stick in your memory
well on George what was particularly
interesting there is while he was a
successful filmmaker he even though he
was not a technical person mm-hmm he
viewed and believed to his core that
technology was going to change the art
of filmmaking mm-hmm so with the success
that he had with Star Wars he was
willing to do something that was not
done anywhere else in the industry so he
was so person that did this hmm and he
said I'm going to invest in bringing
technology into filmmaking mm-hmm and so
that meant not only graphics and but
also meant visual audio and video
editing so I'm not was fortunate to be
connected with George at that time
mm-hmm but he was unique in this why do
you think he decided that what led him
to have that prescience where it seemed
to be lacking in other people what
allowed him well I think the thing that
triggered him and it's not that he ever
told me exactly what the trigger was but
in the making of Star Wars mm-hmm he
required the best use of the advanced
state of the art of special effects at
that time and there were two parts to
that one was the precision control of
optical printing and blue-screen
matting's mm-hmm so this is an optical
process and required a great deal of
technical skill on the part of the
people who were there mm-hm and the
second thing which was a new idea for
Star Wars but was critical for effects
appreciates this but it was there one of
the breakthroughs for the film is that
it's important to have objects blurred
in the direction of motion Oh
interesting
I've yeah that's that makes perfect
sense okay okay and if it doesn't happen
because of the way the projection
systems work then I picked it up and we
actually see a double image but we're
not conscious of it but we're conscious
of something is wrong hmm so what they
did was they had a technical group that
moved the spaceships while the shutter
was open so they captured the blur
on the blue-screen matting film mm-hm
and then with great precision work to
keep that blur of these spaceships as
they then matted the objects together so
this was for the time very high level
technical skill and then Star Wars is
enormous success mm-hmm
and George realized that technical
expertise that was brought in by this
amazing group of people
was one of the things that helped
elevate this fill and put it into a
different category so with that success
he said well let's keep going down this
path how far can we go
mm-hmm because that world outside there
is continuing to change now what's
different about George was he made that
little leap or big leap ahead to do it
from saying technology was a key part of
this to saying oh that world outside is
still changing I'm going to be part of
it and try to incorporate it mm-hmm all
right so that was why he was that way I
don't know but he was the guy that did
it he reminds me of Alfred Lee Loomis
during World War two a Tuxedo Park who
was an amateur scientist but who took a
keen interest in radio and later had a
huge impact on detecting u-boats and
whatnot in the war itself did George and
Steve have anything in common or much in
common well I mean they were quite
different I mean they're very different
from each other
Steve was an extraordinary person and I
wrote him about him at the end of the
book where there I allude to him
throughout the book but there was
something there which I mean I find
especially because I watched the arc of
Steve over his life mm-hmm and the image
of Steve the people know publicly about
the way he worked was from when he was
younger and I witnessed some of those
behaviors and a lot of them weren't nice
at that time mm-hmm
but as a result of being cast out of
Apple and starting next and then buying
Pixar from Lucas Ullman and being part
of starting up Pixar Steve who were so
incredibly intelligent he actually he
just figured out that some of those
things that he did in the past didn't
work and he came
his behavior and he became a more
empathetic person and he changed in the
way that he dealt with them mm-hmm now
what the outside world sees is the
mythology of the young Steve right and
then this also din this gigantic success
of Apple and then the iPhone mm-hmm and
they connect the two together but they
didn't realize the arc that Steve went
through mm-hmm
why did they miss it mm-hmm and the
reason they missed it was that once
Steve went through this change in his
life and he figure this out about 15
years ago then basically everybody that
knew Steve stayed with Steve for the
rest of his life mm-hmm all right so we
all witnessed that part of Steve he was
always an intelligent and incisive than
what he did but his way of working with
people changed
mm-hmm so when it came to the
mythologizing about Steve and people
would call me fern cincin to talk about
him while I was not going to
psychoanalyze Steve while he was alive
right nobody would mm-hmm so why was it
was that why would our boss right yeah
yep so Steve my friend is I mean at the
end it wasn't actually my boss he was on
the board of directors at Disney but for
all those years afterwards that he still
check in all the time and talked and he
had this passionate interest in what was
going on and and he was a caring person
and you know when I was in the hospital
with my hips being replaced know they
were Steven they're visiting and
checking up and wanted to make sure that
had the best medical help and mm-hmm
so that image of Steve was not conveyed
to people because the people that knew
about him viewed him is just of what
their private relationship with Steve so
when we talked about it right so the
mythology about Steve was actually a
mixture of things without recognizing
that as in is your point in Campbell's
book there was this hero's journey right
and Steve went through that journey and
by the end of his life he was a very
different person than he wasn't reversed
what were the reasons this has been sort
of an itch that I have to scratch now
but what were the reasons for IP owing
the
people were skeptical of that he had
well okay so we're we're now making the
first film mm-hmm and to then become a
public company for the rest of us
because none of us have ever been even
in a public company let alone knowing
what it means it's like this could be a
major distraction and you hear the
stories about well okay what does Wall
Street expect does this actually kind of
mislead you into the wrong direction do
you have the wrong values in place
mm-hmm
so there was the view of what let's make
some films and prove our worth and get
that under our belt before we go public
mm-hmm but Steve had a different logic
he said right now we have a
three-picture deal with Disney and the
financial terms of the deal while they
were as good as we could have gotten
under the circumstances once were a
successful company then our share of the
profits were actually pretty small
mm-hmm so Steve wanted to renegotiate
the deal although he had a and always
had a very good relationship with Disney
mm-hmm but Steve said at the end of
three years if we then split off as a
separate company we're no longer with
Disney we will be their worst nightmare
yes we'll have they will have helped
launch a successful competitor mm-hmm
so what will happen is that when Toy
Story comes out now all of this is
before it happens so we're guessing
about again but this is Steve
prognosticating because you now believe
that Stella's gonna be a big success
mm-hmm
so said what will happen is as soon as
the film is out that Michael Eisner will
realize that he's helped create a
competitor so he will want to
renegotiate and if we renegotiate then
what we want is to be 50/50 partners
mm-hmm infinite I should say right there
that's a different Steve than years
before where years where Steve sort of
shot for the fences and try to get
almost everything for himself mm-hmm
he knows reach the pointer he said
that's not a good place to be
mm-hmm a good place to be is a 50/50
partnership so it's like a good standing
um it's a high road to take mm-hmm but
if we're 50/50 partners it also means
that we have to put up half the money
right
what Pixar doesn't have any money yeah
you need a war chest so we need a war
chest so if we go public we will get a
war chest then when we renegotiate we
can come in and go for the kind of deal
which is a 50/50 deal so the film came
out and within a few months still you
got the call from like licensing let's
renegotiate and so she says okay we want
it to be 50/50 and all of that happened
as Steve predicted it would and for me
it was rather amazing yes just wow he's
completely called it correctly that's
incredible and it was coming from a
place of the high ground of a true
partnership that's the way he wanted to
think about it it's a more sustainable
structure right then and through all the
years he ultimately had trouble with
Eisner but it's because he didn't think
Eisner was I partner with him why did he
think that well you know I had to do
with certain things that I've never said
about in the public and so forth and
about Disney and so forth he just didn't
feel like it was a partner relationship
right he would expect mm-hmm and at this
time
Steve had no place value on equitable
partnerships mm-hmm and then there was a
value he brought to the table and in
bringing that because it was a value was
actually could hang on to but he was
always very careful to say Disney itself
as a corporation is one that we really
admire they've done a great job of
marketing our films they've done a
fantastic job with the parks and so
forth so through all of this he worked
very hard to keep a great relationship
with Disney because he believed in the
end that it was going to lead to
something good no guarantees mm-hmm he
was always realistic about that but he
believed that if we be
well with them as partners that would we
would end up in the right place amazing
I really enjoy these stories and when
you get into the the war stories and I
think people would look at stiva they
oftentimes would look at Pixar and say
well my god they're batting a thousand
they've always gotten it right
and what I'd love to ask you is sort of
a two-part it won't be one of my eight
parts questions but what was the hardest
film for you to make and why and then
secondly related to George Lucas I've
I've heard on numerous accounts that he
was hospitalized at least once during
the making of Star Wars with you know
he's I mean a really young guy at the
time but it's just from over exertion
and panic attacks and whatnot that's at
least what I've heard which has been the
hardest for you to make and why and then
do you think for a film to truly be a
landmark film that it is necessary for
at least one person to make a sacrifice
of that magnitude where they just are at
the brink of falling to pieces or not
well I'll answer them reverse world I'm
sure sir and George I wasn't here for
Star Wars one nor for what I was called
the first Star Wars right but in fact I
never heard that so I don't know whether
it was true or false I just I just
didn't hear so I don't know okay but the
bigger question like which is the
hardest they do vary in their hardness I
would say there have been several which
were extremely difficult and some were
only difficult right and I think
originally thought well if she do is T
qualities here but we found that you can
there's something original it's always
hard right even if it's a sequel it
makes it and I would imagine more
difficult some ways yeah because you
have to take them in a different place
and you're constrained by the certain
world that you've got but you're
expected to add something in terms of
that world that really is interesting
not obvious so the only thing that makes
a film hard is if you keep going at it
and it's not working so you can't solve
the problems and then what happens is
for all directors they are emotionally
invested in their films and they also
get lost in them happens to everybody
doesn't matter who they are
mm-hmm whether they're new or whether
they're experienced
and what we have found is that since it
happens to all of them what you want is
this collection of people we call it the
brain trust but essentially it's a group
of colleagues who have been through it
to help navigate it when you're kind of
lost in this swirling mass because it's
very difficult mm-hmm and so the most
difficulty is on the people themselves
and we've had some films where the
original director who had the idea got
lost in it and couldn't get out right
and so we had to make some changes in
order to get the film done so in our
view we've had failures but we basically
we try to keep the failures inside and
it's not that they're secret that we've
had failures hmm but we don't release
the film that fails we will abandon an
or will restart and we've had several
restarts mm-hmm we just get a point say
it's not working we have to do a major
rethink to get this to be where it is so
we have to do that with Toy Story with
ratatouille Wow no kidding
I've seen red I've seen both those
movies dozens of times at what point do
you stop trying to fix something and
abandon it are there cases of total
abandonment and in which case or
shelving something permanently in which
case how do you decide to go completely
scorched earth blank slate as opposed to
reworking something if that's been done
I don't know well usually there's a
buildup that is says all of our films to
begin with sucks
why do you say that just well do the
rough draft is always really rough well
know what it is and this is like the big
misconception that people have is that a
new film was like the baby version of
the final film when in fact sometimes
the final film bears no relationship and
we started off with hmm and what we
found is that first version always sucks
and I don't mean this because I'm
self-effacing or that we're modest about
it I mean it in the sense is that they
really do suck now is this at the
storyboarding level or what how is it
appearing what's the form for the first
version you're going through phases of
where
we know the ideas you pitched the ideas
you rework them then you do a script can
you have a script read you have actors
read through it and then you go through
a couple versions of that and then you
start to storyboard it up and you put it
up and and it isn't until you get to you
know a few versions in that you begin to
find okay these elements of it are
sticking they're holding I can weave now
I've got the tent poles for the film
that we can build around but it's a
discovery process now and the reason it
takes long is you're trying to do
something that's new right if we just
want to throw up a story where it turns
out we know how to do that really
quickly we know how to make it quickly
mm-hmm but it's not a good movie unless
you can try to find some way of touching
people's emotions or bringing something
new to the story so with the reason we
go out on field trips and doing research
trips is that we're trying to take
ourselves and our directors into a place
where they bring something that they
didn't know or in the general audience
wouldn't know mm-hmm and may I use an
example of ratatouille where the
filmmakers went to into the three-star
restaurants in France and then went to
Thomas Keller's French Laundry and so
forth now a lot of people seen The
Cooking Channel but the Cooking Channel
is not like a real it instead of a real
restaurant all right so the thing is
almost nobody has been inside of a real
high-end restaurant so they don't
actually know what goes on inside there
mm-hmm
so when we take elements of the way they
work in the audience and we put them in
the ratatouille as elements then the
audience doesn't know whether they are
true or not because they haven't been
there but they sense that it is right so
when you're watching those people in
that kitchen the way they're working and
the way she's talking because he was
teaching him how to cook right you have
the sense like oh this is real mm-hmm
and you you only get that by going out
into the world and finding something new
and then you bring that in and you have
to meld it into a story
and it's a long slow painful process it
involves a lot of people and a lot of
time so now the question is or what your
question was like you know what do you
do you abandon it or restart how do you
do that okay in our history here we have
only abandoned one film mm-hmm the other
ones we either they evolved into what
they were or we did a restart mm-hmm and
the one that we abandoned the only
reason we abandoned it is that we we
realized we needed to bring fresh blood
in and so the person we brought in said
yes I will do a restart on the film but
since very restarting I have an idea
which I think even better which is a
completely different idea mmm can we
pitch that idea we said you're
absolutely right that's a brilliant idea
what movie did that turn into it's the
one that's coming out next to me okay
okay mm-hmm so rather than being a
restart I would say okay this is this is
the film you're going to do so because
we believed it was a brilliant idea but
for the others it was a restart if you
compare it with baseball like baseball
that's got this notion that you got the
starting pitcher and then you got the
really person and you got the finisher
so you got multiple pitchers in a game
right so there's an ideal and the ideal
is that you'd like to pitch the perfect
game so one guy takes it all the way
through the game and finishes up with a
win so that's the ideal right but the
idea you rarely happens mm-hmm the
concept which we accept is there are
multiple people to do it now in film
when we do something we have someone who
starts it mm-hmm
but their ideal which is to play all the
way through if they don't they go with
you then they think of themselves as
having failed right but if you step back
and say you know they launched the idea
they had a good idea they couldn't
finish it because it's a different kind
of thing when you finish and when you
start mm-hmm the value of the world is
frequently you devalue the first person
then you give high value of the second
person but the reality is it's kind of
all part together and you have to
acknowledge that the fact that the
contributions came from Allah
people over a great length of time and
it's what makes it painful is that in
this world if you have to make that
change it's a personal thing that
somebody has and that's where the pain
comes it's not the work
yeah the feelings definitely well and I
know that you have some time constraints
I'd love if we have a few more minutes
just to ask a couple of rapid-fire
questions that are very short form you
can answer them as briefly as you'd like
and the first of that is what is the
book you've given most often as a gift
the book I've given most often as a gift
mm-hmm I wouldn't say there is a single
one I actually it's customized every
time okay who the person is mm-hmm okay
got it is there any that you've given
more multiple times than others no I I
would say there are certain children's
books sort of given out a few times
that's a good monster after another okay
by Mercer Mayer perfect I love that book
yeah the perfect what is your favorite
documentary or any favorite
documentaries all the documentaries you
know I used to go to Sundance I love
documentaries is their favorite one
though obviously I can't remember a
favor one I for me the documentary gives
us a slice and something we don't see
and so I said I like them as a class
mm-hmm I've been so busy the last couple
years I have no problem watch many
recently are there any lectures
specifically from the teaching company
that stick out in your mind well for me
personally there it is it'll have a
range of things similar video there
science oriented and so forth they've
got them on economics and on Shakespeare
and so forth but the thing that had the
greatest impact on me was the set of
them which was the whole sweep of world
history he hadn't taken my section at a
time
mmm-hmm to do it although I must admit
there was one which was around the time
of King Henry the eighth or that or the
the tutors and the stewards hmm I was so
blown away with that but as soon as I
listened to it I listened to it again
the tutors miss Stewart one I love that
that particular one I'll have to check
that out I will trade you one which is
there's a podcast that only puts that in
episode every three months or so three
or four months called hardcore history
and there's a series called the wrath of
the cons which I highly highly recommend
it it might have the same effect on you
when you think called hardcore hardcore
hardcore history is the podcast and
there's a series there are four or five
parts called wrath of the cons and it's
about as it turns out Jenga scon as
opposed to Genghis Khan it's incredible
and the delivery I did read a book on
Genghis Khan which I thoroughly enjoyed
so this sounds great so it's also it's
all the cons or it covers it covers a
number of different cons but provides
the pretext that the current I would say
the then-current contacts and the
delivery it's a synthesis from many
different sources but give the first
episode a listen and I think that you
will very quickly then devour the entire
series it's it's amazing when you think
of the word successful who is the first
person who comes to mind o successful oh
well you know that's kind of the way I
view success is actually in terms of
people's happiness and mmm-hmm so there
are people that others normally know
about that's okay that's that's the real
success and there are friends and so
forth it I think while they've achieved
this equanimity in life and I just
probably do that a lot whenever I see
people do you meditate by chance not
that you have to I'm just curious I do I
meditate between a half hour an hour a
day and have for several years do you do
that in multiple sessions or single
session typically single session in the
morning in the morning any particular
type of meditation the pasta or TM or
anything else
it's the pas sauna I actually got
started because of visiting this embalm
on center which is Tibetan mm-hm
but in fact because I lived in Marina
when I lived in San Francisco one close
to spirit rock I Oh wonderful become you
know quite engaged with the community
how the spirit rock which is of that
particular style
fantastic two last questions
second-to-last if you could change one
thing about yourself what would it be
well I it's a hard ask because I view
myself as a constantly meeting to change
with others and looking at okay well how
can I do a better job so it's not like
this one thing it's like like well there
are a whole bunch of things where I
would like to evolve or improve and
alter the view and and look at the world
in different ways so for me it's not so
much changing something is can I take on
a different perspective so I understand
or view things I didn't see before
and very perhaps related if you could
give piece of advice or a few pieces of
advice to your say 20 year old self what
would that advice be well you know
that's a it's a tough one because to
some extent if I had told my 20 year old
stuff a lot of things that I know now
just about life I don't know if I would
have understood it mmm so I come into
position work because I think the reason
I wrote a book was to try to explain
things to people right
it's like explaining myself at 20 years
old but the way I view this or any other
book is that you read things or you
learn about them because you want to
figure out how to address issues and
problems in life but the danger is
always that whether it's me or somebody
else is we can look at these things as a
way of somehow sidestepping the problems
mm-hmm and there's a subtle distinction
there and not everybody knows what
they're doing mm-hmm but I think advice
is actually one of like you always face
towards the problem you actually can't
avoid the mess in the middle what you
want are mechanisms to deal with the
mess
mm-hmm and in doing that you will end up
in a better place and you'll get
experiences that you can't get any other
way than by experiencing them what do
you think the advice whether he would
have taken it or not your 20 year old
self most would have needed to hear
would have been well the reason it's
hard is like I've so much enjoyed my
life and the people around it right I'm
aware that if you make it changed and
then the little miniscule changes
actually send you down radically
different paths mm-hmm and so I said
well okay even if I've made mistakes at
the time right what I want to give
myself advice which word had me avoid
that mistake because the mistake was
part of who I am that made me where I am
right so I can look back and say well if
some of those things were painful like I
wish I hadn't done them or done that or
said that but it's not like I could say
well avoid doing that because to some
extent going through the pain of making
that mistake helped alter me right
making me really hard to go back and say
okay do something differently all right
the the unknown butterfly effect or the
unpredictable butterfly effect and what
it could do to the rest well and this
has been a lot of fun I really
appreciate you making the time where
should people learn more about you or
what would you encourage them to go
check out of course I will also put in
the show notes links to the book and
other resources but any any parting
thoughts well I mean we really touched
on the topics of course and when when
we've been here only 50 minutes on this
but for me that all the issues of what
it means to engage with others and
dealing with uncertainty and how you
address fear and how you make safe
environments or critical ones and how
you look at the world and perceive it
and our moral and ethical position in
that environment are all really
important and I don't have any short way
of saying them but to me they're
important and I hope I get at least to
touch down a few of them in the book and
talking about some of our experiences as
we grow as a company and I want to make
it clear that we haven't figured it out
the challenges in front of us every bit
as big as they've always been
as it should be right mountains to climb
I suppose well I can't wait to see what
you guys produce next and given how many
mutual friends we have hopefully will at
some point bump into each other in the
Bay Area but for now at least I will let
you get back to your day and thank you
very much for taking the time alright
thank you very much Jim all right thanks
ed take care
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog comm where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more follow Tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv
or on facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening